cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now for more on the raging
coronavirus
outbreak david good morning a big
picture here
back in march you were the first to call
lockdowns and quarantines
where exactly are we headed right now
michelle 180 000 cases in a day which
means the real number is probably closer
to a million
when you take into account asymptomatic
people and people who aren't testing
we're in a position where we really have
to have a mass mandate we have to change
behavior
there's hope on the horizon the vaccines
but we
really have to start to do something
because each one of those 180
000 or a million depending on how you
look at it have family members and
they're going home and talking to others
and the virus
keeps spreading doctors speaking of
family thanksgiving is coming up here
aaa is estimating 50 million americans
will travel for the thanksgiving holiday
most of them driving but a lot flying
what what would you tell families right
now
well if you really want to get together
with family you need to start
quarantining now
and really not go out so that you're
assured
you have not been exposed to the virus
by the time thanksgiving happens
or when you get together wear masks and
put the tables far apart
and have a buffet so everybody can do
this safely
it is critical that we do this right or
the case numbers are going to continue
to go up and we're going to lose lives
that shouldn't be lost
you mentioned the hope of a vaccine we
know with pfizer right now they're
saying 90
effective we're hearing that we're going
to get some type of numbers and word
from moderna possibly this week
so look ahead a month as far as vaccines
and then even six months where are we
so i mean these vaccines are hope in a
bottle you've got pfizer with greater
than 90
efficacy you've got moderna coming and
you have astrozenic accompanying which
means
we will have 80 to 90 million doses by
the end
by december and we will start to
vaccinate the country
and so it's going to take anywhere up to
six months to start to vaccinate people
across you know first with healthcare
workers then with the highest need
individuals and frontline workers and
then with the rest of the country
but this vaccine will work we've seen
the data
and it is safe and so really there is
hope light at the end of the tunnel
so if we change our behavior today with
that light at the end of the tunnel
the outcome is not going to be as dire
as some of the pundits are saying now
if we don't it's going to be a really
rough six months till we vaccinate the
country
david is there a concern though about
people being leery of taking a vaccine
and how do the medical professionals get
past that
well i mean danny you bring up a great
point is that certainly yeah there has
not been
real data on the vaccine till monday and
monday you know
i was literally in tears greater than 90
efficacy blocking the virus and at the
same time
with over 90 000 people vaccinated
around the globe there has yet to be a
serious adverse event related to the
vaccines
so certainly very very encouraging as we
get more data
myself and many others are going to
stand up and start to explain it and it
looks like the data are going to make
sense that the benefits dramatically
outweigh the negatives everyone is
saying we don't have long-term data
well almost every vaccine in history the
side effects were seen in the first
month or two and we have
several months experience with all of
these vaccines
and they are remarkably well tolerated
really good to know and important to
point out about
any of those side effects dr david agus
thank you